and apparently fairly Logan Paul has a
podcast now it's called impulsive you
see what he did there
impulsive no he plugged it when he was
apologizing about the the tree thing
yeah but now it's finally out every
episode came out on the 19th of November
I think you said something like it's
pretty impulsive the way I did that did
he
I thought it was something like that
really it was pretty like thing it's a
pretty shitty name for him to choose
impulsive impulsive like just I mean
it's like just a bad pun but it's also
like in in retrospect the things he's
done yeah probably
impulsive wasn't the right choice for a
title of your podcast yeah yeah express
how much you've changed yeah I'm still
impulsive man whatever my name is my
name's Paul it's in the word no I'm a
change guy but I'm like I still do
impulsive [ __ ]
yeah no I'm Paul Civ yeah he's
rebranding from Logan Paul - Paul Civ
I'm Paul Civ I'm Paul civilized what if
it's a completely subdued podcast Paul
Civ no I'm Paul Civ why does everyone
think it's impulsive Paul Civ - creator
formerly known as Logan Paul on this
podcast I will be discussing the order
of operations and social structure when
it comes to public behavior mom this
[ __ ] sucks it's I don't know why I'm
laughing so hard
someone impulsive trying to start a
podcast called impulsive
I am pulsing like impulsive no no it's
not impulsive it's my name Paul Civ I'm
Paul Civ impulse and Paul says your
name's Paul oh I see you it's a little
play on words no it's not a play on
words it's just my name got it I'm Paul
Civ got it you're I'm Paul said that's
me
I'm the host I'm Paul Civ how do you not
but if you keep saying it faster I'm
Paul Civ Keep Calm I'm Paul Civ it's my
name impulsive it's not impulsive
impulsive it's not impulsive let's hear
the first episode okay let's hear the
third one cuz the third one is called I
gave summer Rae the D that's so
cool dude it's bound to be good that's
so cool that's bound to be good let's
see what we got oh that this already
this already is so annoying
yeah holy God you know that max that's
fax that's sign oh you want to know what
else is lit sucking toes why is this
sound like the opening credits to next
yo what's up i'm logan paul and welcome
to my podcast i'm here with my roommates
yo it's Dee Spence I'm a vegan I love
plants
he loves plants I'm 23 I love plants and
I'm ready to plant my seed deep in
Christina your teeth are yellow next
next what what that cannot be [ __ ]
true let's have a look is that true Cody
bought a get pissed off about the
analytics yep I'm about to end it all if
this is true let's see Brow's top charts
I hope to god this is not true podcast
not true at all dog number one is Conan
Conan O'Brien needs a friend
we're coming for you Conan it's not even
on the [ __ ] top fifty dude [ __ ]
liar dude that's that is a horse [ __ ]
maybe maybe he just said that thank you
thank you for making my podcast the top
podcast in the world not like Cody's
about to do the what right now what
you're setting the record straight
you're doing the what I'm just saying
like not like not like quantifiably like
it's not like you can't lace on the
charts not number one or whatever but in
my opinion it's about it's that
it's definitely the best and like people
have told me that it's the best so thank
you for making it the best
yeah for sure oh they're joking it was a
joke damn he opened this opened it
opened it with the sponsor I hate this
too I hate [ __ ] he just jumps into
[ __ ] and just just assumes he's the
[ __ ] best at it and then you can do
you can telling his voice today we got
an awesome sponsor you guys like so
stoked up to do a podcast wait a year
man this [ __ ] gets [ __ ] boring no man
I don't care boring is not a good word
you know what it is it's [ __ ] I feel
pressure man recently for the podcast a
little bit ya know yeah I feel like I
have to come here one up myself I get
like after so I mean it's just like
anything but after squad 680 that's
tough man never never gonna get better
than that dude the fifth episode man I
can't like how many like things I was
like on stream i was recanting okay yeah
what's that again when you can't even
and you just gotta okay you gotta join
in the end I recant ya recanting okay
just all the stupid bits I've come up
with for the podcast and I just I don't
know I feel like all these things that I
try to me this will be funny okay like
look through the comments no one
acknowledges the thing that I was like
alright alright alright okay yeah I
think penny wise was probably our best
one in a minute it was very [ __ ]
funny then but then I will say like
going back and like thinking and like in
the chat people were bringing up like
random bits like little pump on the
Bachelorette and stuff right okay like I
feel like these yeah I feel we've been
diligent and like trying to be funny
yeah you know I I want it I want to know
I want to know what impulsive his life
someone listen to a full episode and
report back yes some
[ __ ] I've got some clothes is that
Dustin clothes I got some clothes
these are Dustin phone these are custom